when you hear constant of
proportionality it can seem a little bit
intimidating at first it seems very
technical but as we'll see it's a fairly
intuitive concept and we'll do several
examples and hopefully you'll get a lot
more comfortable with it so let's say
we're trying to make some type of baked
goods maybe it's it's some type of
muffin and we know that depending on how
many muffins were trying to make that
for a given number of eggs we always
want twice as many cups of milk
so we could say cups of milk cups of
milk that's going to be equal to two
times the number of eggs so what do you
think the constant of proportionality is
here sometimes known as the
proportionality constant well yes it is
going to be two this is a proportional
relationship between the cups of milk
and the number of eggs the cups of milk
are always going to be two times the
number of eggs give me the number of
eggs I'm going to multiply it by the
constant of proportionality to get the
cups of milk and we can see how this is
a proportional relationship a little bit
clearer if we set up a table so if we
say number of eggs and if we say cups of
milk and make a table here well if you
have one egg how many cups of milk
you're gonna have well this right over
here would be one times two well you're
gonna have two cups of milk if you add
three eggs well you're going to multiply
that by two to get your cups of milk so
you're gonna have six cups of milk if
you had 1 million eggs so we have a very
big party here maybe we're some type of
industrial muffin producer
well how many cups of milk will you put
a million in right over here multiply it
by two you get your cups of milk you're
going to need two million cups of milk
and you can see that this is a
proportional relationship to go from
number of eggs 2 cups of milk we indeed
multiplied by 2 every time that came
straight from this equation and you can
also see look whenever you multiply your
number of eggs by a certain amount
you're multiplying your cups of milk by
the same amount
if I multiply my eggs by a million I'm
multiplying my cups of milk by a million
so this is clearly a proportional
relationship but let's get a little bit
more practice identifying the constant
of proportionality so let's say I'll
make it a little bit more abstract let's
say I have some variable a and it is
equal to five times some variable B what
is the constant of proportionality here
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out
yes it is five give me a B I'm gonna
multiply it by five and I can figure out
what a needs to be let's do another
example if I said that Y is equal to PI
times X what is the constant of
proportionality here well you give me an
X I'm gonna multiply it times a number
the number here is PI to give you Y so
our constant of proportionality here is
PI let's do one more if I were to say
that Y is equal to 1/2 times X what is
the constant of proportionality pause
this video think about it well once
again this is just going to be the
number that we're multiplying by X to
figure out why so it is going to be one
half in general you might sometimes see
it written like this Y is equal to K
times X where K would be some constant
that would be our constant of
proportionality you see the one half is
equal to K here pi is equal to K right
over there
so hopefully that helps